for the four Democratic senators running
for president the sprint back to the
campaign trail will happen the second
the impeachment trial gavels out today
they will race from Washington to Iowa
with just nine days to go until the Iowa
caucus ed O'Keefe is in Des Moines this
morning Edie good morning good morning
Michele as you mentioned those senators
running for president planned to race
off two flights out of DC as soon as the
trial wraps and while they've been on
jury duty we noticed they've deployed a
diverse cast of characters to help them
out senators Elizabeth Warren Amy
Klobuchar and Bernie Sanders are running
for a new job but I've been stuck in
Washington doing their day jobs speaking
to CBS on Friday Warren and Sanders
admitted it's been a tough juggling look
some things are more important than
politics I took an oath to uphold the
Constitution we are now in only the
third impeachment trial in the entire
history of the United States of course I
am here so it is disappointing to me not
to be an are talking to the people there
but don't you think it's an important
business here well of course it isn't I
am accepting my constitutional
responsibility in their absence the
senators running for president have sent
friends and family out on the road on
Friday night New York congresswoman
alexandria Ocasio Cortes campaigned for
Sanders in Iowa it's not that we can't
it's that we're scared while at the
other end of the state filled Rob Nick
the coach of the 2018 US Olympic gold
medal curling team campaign for
Klobuchar at an Iowa curling club clova
charts daughter is also hosting hot dish
house parts with supporters
so she's she's there but I'm here as she
said she's a mom so she can do two
things at once
earlier in the week former presidential
candidate who Leon Castro campaigned for
war just nine days remain until the Iowa
caucus on Friday in Des Moines a convoy
of snowplows started clearing the
streets in anticipation of large crowds
and out-of-town caucus traffic and
huyang the only candidate in the state
on Friday talked up his idea for Student
Loan Relief mile in New Hampshire former
Vice President Joe Biden said Republican
attacks on him aren't working
have you ever seen the president spent
so much time trying to keep someone from
being a nominee
I wonder why in that interview with
Norah O'Donnell senator Sanders admitted
that yes he's perhaps that a bit of a
disadvantage by being stuck in
Washington and leaving the campaign
trail to candidates like Joe Biden or
Pete Buddha jets but Dana Sanders is
back out here tonight all right and if
you're looking for something to do I'll
send you my old home address you can go
swing by and take a selfie there great
sounds good
[Laughter]